hi I'm Charlize Theron and I'm David
Etowah and this is a wired auto-complete
interview rough day what is Charlize
Theron middle name I don't have a middle
name you don't I don't and I'm kind of
sad about it you should be I have eight
my mom has 13 and I think because she
has so many names she just decided she
was and you know the pendulous you just
yeah what is Charlize Theron face shape
fact what is Charlize Theron zodiac sign
leo
what is Charlize Theron's IQ in question
we're not sure middling too high
what is Charlize Theron's tattoo do you
have one I have a few I'm several you're
a really good friend of mine you should
know I have the middle names of my kids
they have middle names I was not a lazy
mother and then I have a flower on my
foot yeah I've seen that one I went
swimming it shows my feet in your face
quite a lot and then I have a fish on my
ankle which is even younger but I did
that one with my mom so that was pretty
special
what is Charlize Theron's life story Wow
okay I will be back we reschedule yeah
reschedule the rest of the day this is
gonna take a bit oddest 7th 1975 my have
a car a baby genius was born it was very
good it was good
is David a yellow the first black James
Bond oh wow I like that technically
because I did an audio book or trigger
mortis playing James Bond
so technically yes is David a yellow
British yes I am
Wow is David a yellow royal what's
actually true I am a prince
fancy-pants my grandfather was a king of
a part of Nigeria called our way is
David Aylor a prince yes I just answer
that I am are you really a prince I am
does that change things yes much nicer
gee this happens a lot I know royalty is
David a yellow bow in family feud the
Jay Z video yes I am oh I thought it was
the TV show family food that would have
been cool no the very cool Jay Z video
as directed by Ava Duvernay whatever
jealousy does Charlize Theron have kids
yes I have two kids that I know of those
Shirley's Theron have an accent I don't
think I have an accent anymore I mean I
mess up my grammar and from it's all
relative guys everyone has an accent
guys royalty and smart
I'm Charlize Theron's use a body double
I thought that's a booby double I don't
think I've used a body double
I mean look I've been in this for a long
time so I might be wrong but most of the
time that's just me does Charlize Theron
have an Oscar yeah as I do
does Charlize Theron play the banjo
Charlize Theron does not play the banjo
but I played a character on Arrested
Development who plays the banjo really
well see you had a double for that no I
did it myself you learned to play the
banjo
no I faked play it but we're actors
David no okay it's got to be real where
is David Oyelowo from I was born in the
UK my parentage is Nigerian and I'm
legally American where is Debra yellow
we'll go to school obviously did not go
to school cuz he can't read drama guys
most of my schooling was in Nigeria I
went to st. Saviour's in epitome Etta in
Lagos and then I went to George Orwell
School in London
sound like real schools to me where our
David our yellow as parents from my dad
is from all your state in Western idea
and my mom from Edo state in eastern
Nigeria where is David or yellow a
mother I'm just gonna move on this I
don't even understand that question
where does David a yellow rosemary
somebody wants to come and knock on your
door at 3:00 a.m.
don't do it no way we'll take I will
take say I live in Los Angeles where is
Charlize Theron oh right now we're in a
secretive government building can't tell
you anything more where is Charlize
Theron Oh
originally from I was born in a small
town called Benoni in South Africa where
was Charlize Theron discovered I don't
know I mean there's a story that I was
discovered by a manager and a bank is
that much for what he discovered me
there you know then other people
discovered me I'm constantly being
discovered
where did Charlize Theron go to school
lower school I went to a little school
called quit full-time which literally
translates to pit fountain and then a
high school I went to the art school in
Johannesburg should I keep going please
where did Charlize Theron well I grew up
in the area I was just talking about bit
Fontaine Fontaine that's all Dane that's
one thing
what is David a yellow us age holy I
think I am I'm 41
what is David a yellow is height I am 5
foot 9 what is David elo is heritage wow
you guys are really fascinated by where
I'm from you should just say what you
feel
yeah what do you feel like deep down in
your groin do we really want to go
technically I'm now British
african-american that's the first time
I've kind of discovered that guy it's so
wonderful to share this moment in my
life with you just felt bad
you in the middle name you do yeah I can
take all the sympathy in the world so I
have eight David where you're talking
about an imam ahmad she could be or
europa and I've like forgotten three
proposed did you really yeah I'm gonna
learn those I want to be that kind of
friend who knows all your middle names
really yeah I'm gonna nominate your Coco
Wow